we're going to expose Harvard for the
lies they are GOP Harvard graduates send
scathing letter blasting schools
response to Pro Hamas students abhorent
Harvard has faced heated criticism after
student groups expressed support for
Hamas after its attack on Israel take a
look at this tweet from James Lindsay
how it started and how it's going it's a
good one in the first one there a quote
despite being the most acclaimed
academic institution in the country
Harvard received a 0.00 point Free
Speech ranking on 100 point scale a full
11 points behind the next worst school
and then the response from the Harvard
president over the uh pramas protests
our University Embraces a commitment to
free expression that commitment extends
even to views that many of us find
objectionable even outrageous we do not
punish or sanction people for expressing
such views that's absolutely hilarious
because they have criticized and
condemned conservatives in the past yeah
the fact that they're unwilling to
criticize this group and they're
actually saying well you know they're
allowed to do it shows Harvard overtly
supports what these students are saying
the institutions are absolutely
corrupted but as horrifying as this the
situation uh in Israel is we are now
seeing the left overtly supporting acts
of Terror killing of children capturing
and killing of civilians and uh I'm I I
appreciate their free speech I'm glad
they're saying the things they're saying
yeah I mean but and and yet it is it is
so poignant for me to see liberals
liberals of the old stripe and here I'm
actually thinking of the former Harvard
president Larry Summers I don't know if
you saw his statement he's like I'm so
bitterly grieved that an institution to
which I have been affiliated with for
most of my adult life is uh you know has
has sort of broken with the principles
and and was now taking the side of the
terrorists and I was thinking wow Larry
Summers if anyone would say who's the
embodiment of Harvard over the last 50
years they would say you you're the
example of the kind of classical liberal
that Sur surrendered to the left over
the past several that enabled the
leftist Takeover of these institutions
cuz conservatives never ran these
institutions when I was a student at
Dartmouth I would say it was the old
line liberals who were in charge and the
new Left pushing up against them and the
change in the in the college to today
would be that that that Insurgent group
is now completely in charge and the old
line liberals have been pushed aside but
the old line liberals let it happen and
they're now in a sense living with the
fruit of it it's a little bit like some
of these women on the subway you know
these Bohemian women who are approached
by people who like punched them and
slapped them and you feel sorry for them
but you're like isn't this what you
voted for right you know if if this if
this this guy had come and slapped some
other woman and you saw it you'd be like
don't go after that guy he's a victim of
racism you know let's not black lives
matter so you've got this they they get
hit and go help help I'm being oppressed
that's right when it happens to them
suddenly the rules change it's like when
Elon Musk banned like those five
journalists leftists on Twitter for like
one day not only do they go nuts I mean
they were quoting John Stewart Mill I
mean they were discovering the virtues
of Free Speech but only because it was
happening to them yeah yeah so
ex yeah and there in lies the big
challenge but now I mean some of them
stay true to their principles there's
that woman uh whose boyfriend was
murdered in front of her and the reports
are that she's refusing to identify the
murderer what but the conspiracy theory
on the on on on uh X Twitter is that it
was a hit yeah I heard that it's like
you know I don't know about that but I
got to be honest are you really going to
come out and claim to the police that
the reason you're not not identifying
the Killer is because that would be
racist are the cops going to believe
that be like really someone murdered
your boyfriend in front of him and
you're like but if he goes to jail it's
racist so whoopsie so a lot of people
are convinced like there's no way
someone watches their loved one die in
front of them and then tell and then
says but because of racism I think the
killer should be free unless they wanted
it to happen I mean it's easier if
you're a journalist and you know the
suspect is black but you leave that fact
out of the article which we've been
seeing in recent decades but then at
least you are not facing the
consequences it's easy for it's it's
kind of virtue on the cheap I'm not
going to mention that he's block but you
know I get some virtue points but but
it's a whole another matter if somebody
comes and kills your kid and and and
your facing and you're you're not
willing to say okay that guy did it this
in in the culture War a lot of uh
parents that we see up it's because
they're finally being impacted by it and
it's it's an unfortunate reality many
years ago Irving crystal said that
neoconservatism which we've got a lot of
problems with these days but
neoconservatism is when a liberal is
mugged by reality and um and and that
happens to people we're seeing it now
with Hamas yeah have you seen that Meme
I don't know I can try and pull it
up it's uh I'll try and find it the the
the political persuasion you gain when
uh I don't know I I'll have to find it
uh at some point but it shows all the
different things that turns you into
various political ideologies so it's
like this graph and it shows you get you
you you pay your April April 20th and
it's like become libertarian then it's
like gets mugged become
conservative you know gets speeding
ticket becomes liberal is war on there
war starts become authoritarian no no no
like it's not on there I don't know I'll
try and find it but you guys think
that's natural and and actually a good
thing that we become more authoritarian
when we're our livelihoods are
threatened by War well I mean look um
I'm making this film as you guys know
police state and I had to think to
myself how did this come to America
because a police state is very alien to
America and then I realized
that
paradoxically this was a bipartisan
creation of the aftermath of 9/11
because a lot of Americans out of fear
were like listen we got these foreign
terrorists who knows when this is going
to happen again we need to stop the next
guy so we're going to give the
government all these new surveillance
Powers we're going to basically give him
a card blanch do whatever you want never
thinking that 10 years later they would
take all that Armory of resources and
then turn it domestically and say all
right we now have a new Target domestic
extremists right uh and uh that changes
the whole game so that in my view was
the the sort of Genesis of the American
police state kind of a knee-jerk
reaction almost to being under attack
without thinking about the long-term uh
possibilities of that yeah well when
you're under when you're in fear and
you're in fear of attack you tend to go
to by any means necessary that's a
normal reaction I mean that that's what
you would think if Outlaw surrounded
your house I got I need to fight this by
any means necessary and and that's what
leads you to think I'm going to give the
government these powers that I wouldn't
normally give them this is why the left
love Co same thing they're like Co
creates a wartime environment in which
people are full of fear and when you're
full of fear you also trust experts
here's a man in a white lab coat take
this this pill will make you feel better
you're like oh okay no one's going to be
like well why are you giving me these
tests doctor what are these tests really
for and what does this pill really do
you defer to people who supposedly are
experts on all this and so this is a a
wonderful way for the left to make
political
advances operating through the fear of
the American people do you think there
are environments where you can kind of
change your Society into a military
Society a militra without it turning on
itself well the the Spartans did that
for centuries they had a very
militaristic culture and they would they
would train kid they essentially had
martial acmy as a substitute for schools
and fighting was their education and
they were the best at it and they
developed all these amazing techniques
basically You' you'd have a failan and
everybody would hold a shield you're not
defending yourself with your Shield your
Shield defends the guy to the right and
you're defended by The Shield of the guy
to your left and so the Spartans would
move in the fail lanks I mean they were
so formidable that in the pipian war the
Greeks could not fight them so the the
the Athenians decided when the war
started we're going to abandon all our
land and go to Sea because we can't
fight the Spartans one-on-one we'll let
the Spartans come and take all our land
however eventually the weakness of the
Finks was discovered and they began
flanking them mhm well not only that but
the Spartans also didn't like technology
apparently someone came to the Spartan
King aradus and told him we've invented
a way to launch a projectile so we don't
actually have to fight manto man and the
Spartan King said I will give you a
reward speak to no one about this
invention because if this invention
becomes widespread basically military
Valor will disappear in Sparta wow so
they were more concerned with
maintaining the military virtue than
having this kind of new Gadget there
there's something to that though with
the uh ad EV of um the cartridge you
ended up with conscription I mean
there's always some form of conscription
but but widespread military conscription
came to be when you didn't need to train
people yes CU anyone could fight as soon
as you had uh so obviously with the
musket you start seeing more and more of
it there's always some kind of we have
to go and fight to varying degrees but
then when you got the uh the reloadable
cartridge you end up with the US going
to all these countries and being like
not necessarily the us but many weapons
manufacturers and saying now your
farmers can fight hand them this tell
them to point and click all they need to
be trained is how to reload and they're
going to miss a whole lot but it doesn't
matter you don't need to know technique
anymore I watched that movie I think
it's the Last Samurai I could be wrong
Tom Cruz it might have been The Last
Samurai maybe not I don't know I watched
a movie where it was uh uh I think
that's what it was it's it's in the
1800s and it's around when theend the M
yeah and so the samurai who are trained
and were these Elites were no longer
necessary and they were losing political
power yes right that's crazy and soon
it's going to be a dude in a pod in an
underground base with a headset on
flying a drone yeah we're already
basically there but I mean like the
future of warfare is going to be silly
because be drones fighting drones yeah
that's so true you're going to be in a
factory and you're going to be in a
conflict Zone and then it's going to be
like the alarm's going to go off and
it's like flee all the humans are going
to evacuate and there going to be a
bunch of weird drones who crashing into
each other and robot dogs shooting at
each other and we'll see another sparik
situation where the people from the
military industrial complex and the
governments are going to be like no we
want to use the weapons that we have we
really want to use our F7 we got to use
our longrange intercontinental ballistic
missiles and at the same time you're
getting ripped apart by drones or some
stupid new tech that's like well if we
use that then we're not going to be able
to use our toys it's like you you got to
adapt you're going to have to adapt
really rapidly to the new type of War I
mean look it was in the what was the '
80s Terminator the the concept of an AI
taking over our weapons before we even
had developed techn it's really
incredible it leads me to believe we're
probably going to build warp engines and
go travel the Galaxy because in the'80s
when computers were trash they were like
one day computers will be so strong and
so smart they'll take everything over
now we're looking at Ai and it's
terrifying I mean the the genius of that
movie Terminator one I think was the
best but two was pretty good too is that
it made a an accurate call in a way that
earlier science fiction never did you go
back and read HG Wells you know in the
early part of the 20th century and he
has the idea that you'd have these
massive lumbering robots like 20 feet
tall with big legs you know and they'd
be doing all this work for us but but
Terminator I think was a very
thought-provoking movie in its own way
and underestimated at the time but in in
retrospect I think it's like one of
these movies like sha Shank Redemption
over time it gets better we I I think
Terminator 2 was the big one like
Terminator was good they made a sequel
and Terminator 2 was just like was huge
huge Guns and Roses had a song in it um
obviously what Eddie like needs to be
the good guy Sarah Conor I mean it was
the it was a female uh hero the thing
like the main character was this badass
woman it was awesome like alien it was
James James Cameron same director as
alien so he's really good at creating at
that point he was what's your fear with
AI have you been studying it have you
done any documentaries on it yet I
haven't um no but it's um no I think
it's it changes the rules of the game in
so many ways I was telling Tim earlier
that I walk into my podcast you know and
um the the guy who's my does the
technical work on the podcast he took my
last podcast and he put in some Ai and
there I am speaking fluent Spanish and
uh my mouth is moving and I'm and my
wife who Venezuela and she's like oh my
she was like stunned you know speechless
for a moment because so think about
think about the the POS just from that
simple idea the possibilities of
manipulation I mean I can see the
promise of it but I can also see the
Peril of it here's here's the start
within a within a couple years YouTube
rolls out the autot translate button oh
yeah that will just press a button and
then all a sudden everyone speaking
Spanish or German or Japanese and then
from there you have the technology to
just create a podcast you could
literally just we're we're we're almost
to the point where you can type in to
one of these AIS give me an episode of
timcast IRL with Alex Jones Joe Rogan
and Donald Trump and it will AI generate
the whole thing and it will seem real
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 P.M
and become a member over at timcast.net